or volunteers. Thank you so much for choosing to listen to us in a crowded media landscape.
Support for The Herb Doctor comes from Tony Jones, who provides "Neozeohealing," a hands-on
healing philosophy where together Tony and her client can explore old patterns and beliefs
that no longer serve. Once empowered, with new perspectives, different choices can be
made moving towards a life that's truly desired. Contact Tony Jones at 707-223-2724 for further
information or to schedule an appointment.
Support for KMUD comes from Redwood Coast Energy Authority, who provides services and support
to the community to build energy resilience, reduce energy consumption, and expand the
use of climate-friendly electric vehicles. Visit redwoodenergy.org for complete details
or call 707-269-1700 for more information.
Thank you.
[music]
Okay, well, welcome to this month's edition of Ask Your Herb Doctor. It's March the 18th,
2022. Excuse a few technical hitches we had there, but we are live now. You're listening
to Ask Your Herb Doctor on KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM. From 7.30 to the end of the show at
8 o'clock, callers are invited to call in with questions related to this month's continuing
topic of mTOR and a further discussion of holistic versus mechanistic approaches to
the treatment of disease. So, I think without further ado, let's introduce Dr. Raymond Peat,
who once again is joining us. Dr. Peat, are you with us?
Well, thank you, as always, for giving your time. And as always, I'm constantly reminded
of people who have never heard of alternatives. I'm not joking. I'm serious. And I guess I
just cannot take it for granted, and I'm sure you don't take it for granted either that
some people just don't know that there are alternatives to the standard model. Now, whether
it's treatment or chemicals or whatever it is, but alternatives exist. And so, for those
people who are listening, both now and who will pick this up on the audio archives at
some point in the future, would you just give an outline of your academic and professional
backgrounds of people that are listening can hear about you?
Before I studied biology in graduate school, I was studying linguistics, literature, psychology
and teaching in those areas, and I decided I needed a more technical science background
to understand how the brain works in the humanities and language and so on. So, I, in 1968, went
to graduate school at the University of Oregon in biology, and did my dissertation, finished
in 1972, in the area of reproductive physiological aging, the changes of oxidative metabolism
during aging and its effect on reproduction. And I've been applying insights and related
things to all sorts of problems in the 50 years since then.
All right, well thank you, thank you for that. So, for those of you who are listening now,
who take callers from 7.30 to the end of the show at 8 o'clock, the number is 707 923 3911.
Once again, 707 923 3911. So, Dr. Peat, I think what I'd like to do, you're exquisitely aware
of this, no doubt, but just for those who are listening tonight, and like I said, who will
listen to the archives, I wanted to carry on last month's topic of the findings around
research of which there's lots of papers written in 2022, 21 and 2020, based on the concept
of mTOR, the mechanistic target of rapamycin, and its use in cancer. And I think the bulk
of the evening show is going to remain based on the alternative approaches to cancer. What
we do here is we like to give the scientific background for the relevance of certain substances,
whether natural or synthetic, even, used to be a better approach to treatment of disease.
What I wanted to ask you, Dr. Peat, just to give an outline yourself even, on how the alternatives
have been usurped in many ways by the modern approach to disease and how the machinery
which drives that research, if it is true research at all, is corrupted by the interests
of financial and vested interests, because we really haven't made hardly any significant
increases in our knowledge of the treatment of cancer in particular. So with tonight's
discussion a continuation of last month's and previous other shows based on alternatives,
would you just give an outline of the prior history of those thinkers like St. Georgie
and numerous others you've discussed just ad lib in describing other processes that
we've just used for a radio show topic in the past, how the thinking of these classical
people that are steeped in biology and not in mechanistic approaches, how that's changed
and what we are currently faced with in medicine, which doesn't seek to treat people holistically,
let alone scientifically in some cases?
Yeah, the mechanistic materialist view, reducing everything to a cause and effect relation
between two simple bits of matter, that makes everything seem absolutely clear to the people
who have defined science that way. But when you focus on the interaction of two or just
a few particles you can understand those very clearly, but when you're focused that way
you miss the whole context. The people like Warburg and Szent-Györgyi looked at the whole
picture of biology. Warburg saw things that happened in yeast, saw them happening in cancer,
the production of lactic acid even in the presence of oxygen and had the insight that
this is something very important about the nature of life. Szent-Györgyi was following
up on some other insights by other people such as W.F. Koch and worked out the classical
present view of how oxidation and mitochondrial metabolism work, but he kept in mind the whole
organism and what's going on at every level of water and energy supply interactions, so
on every conceivable thing that feeds into the life process and didn't focus on the
few reductionistic material interactions that ordinary science does and as a result Warburg's
work was ridiculed and ignored for about 50 years, more than 50 years. It was only around
the beginning of this century that things he did in the 1920s started to be appreciated
but generally misunderstood and Szent-Györgyi's work on cancer involved things that biologists
and doctors had never heard of or even thought of or even could think of, the idea of what
electrons in water are doing and how motion is the essential feature of life and it's
powered by the organized flow of electrons and he applied that to cancer, as well as
muscle function and circulation. Every aspect of biology can be re-understood in terms of
very simple things that act everywhere. There's no single place in metabolism where electrons
and water and muscles react to produce motion. It's a fundamental quality of life. So the
really scientific work done attempting to understand the organism in terms of everything
that can be known about it scientifically, the mainline science people are blind to that
because it doesn't at all fit into reductionistic materialism or mechanistic materialism.
I think the concept of looking for a cause and an effect driving that kind of mechanistic
approach has largely ignored the concept of a living organism interacting with its environment
and being effected directly by its environment. In looking at your newsletter that you publish
quarterly now, isn't it? You mentioned the presence and the absolute knowledge of the
cancer field as a, not as a theory, but as a reality. I think for people that are listening,
just to understand that not only the concept of the bystander effect exists whereby if
a cell is irradiated outside of the body and is introduced into the body, that it can have
a similarly damaging effect, not because it's typically releasing high energy electrons,
but because the stress signals that the cell will give out as a result of being irradiated
have a direct effect on other cells. It comes into either into direct contact with or at
a distance. And that is a reality. It's almost like a quantum physical event that I think
only probably with the last 10 or 15 years of science opening up quantum theory, are
we able to put it into that place where we can begin to imagine such a thing has actually
happening?
If people were demonstrating the phenomenon 60 years ago, they knew that if you X-rayed
an animal, you didn't have to X-ray the brain and pituitary to cause generalized hormonal
changes. For example, it would cause the animal to go into heat, or females. If you irradiated
their foot, the same thing would happen. The whole organism would shift, shift its hormonal
balance towards reproductive heat. And that is an example of the whole body as a cancer
field. The signal from the radiation is a holistic stress on the whole organism that
spreads something that promotes cancer. The mainstream biologists and medical people are
still insisting that radiation causes spot damage to the DNA, causes a mutation in one
gene of the DNA, and that that mechanistic one-to-one damage somehow works its way out,
ending up as a cancer. But that simply isn't a realistic picture. The radiation doesn't
have to hit the DNA. It does something excitatory and pro-inflammatory to the organism separate
from anything that might do to the DNA. And that general stress reaction to radiation
turns on these signals that transmit estrogen-like signals all through the body. And people have
found out that you can treat radiation poisoning and estrogen poisoning in the same way. And
if you add radiation to estrogen, you've added a defective of the damage.
Dr. Peat, this is why you strongly recommend against any form of radiation, but specifically
dental x-rays because x-rays damage fastly dividing cells. And when you have a dental
x-ray, it's affecting your brain, which is very rapidly dividing your eyes and your thyroid.
And tongue cancer, tonsil cancer, eye cancer, and brain cancer have all increased along
with the incidence or intensity of dental x-rays. A study in Seattle several years ago,
I put a lead field over the abdomen of pregnant women and found that a full set of dental
x-rays with thyroid and pelvis and everything shielded by lead caused, if they were pregnant
at the time, it caused the babies to be born underweight, underdeveloped the same way any
stress or excess estrogen would do.
So the stress of that dental x-ray spread all the way down to the uterus and the developing
baby?
I wanted to just briefly get into the term "cancer field" before we both open up the
lines at 7.30 and get into the subject of mTOR and phosphoinositide 3-kinase as well
as AKT as a triple pathway with which cancer is now being studied. And a lot of natural
products with these blocking activities are being trialed and used already in phase two
trials for cancer, very many different cancers.
But for people that are listening, we talked about the bystander effect and how just the
fact that you can damage a cell and reintroduce it into the body, it can still cause damage
in the body it's been introduced into, not because the body's been damaged, but the
cell has an alarm signal that is basically propagated throughout the organism and has
a bystander effect on other healthy cells.
Well the same thing with the cancer field, you wrote in your January newsletter that
the cancer field is very similarly set up in such that the actual tumor itself in a
radiating pattern out from the tumor has differing degrees of damage to the cells, so essentially
there's a radiating pattern of damage from the central tumor out to distant tissues beyond
the tumor that are precancerous and that is propagated by a direct pathway that is similar
to the bystander effect.
Yeah, any of the intense stresses like oxygen or glucose deficiency will reduce the efficient
oxygen metabolism and cause stress signals and when one particular area is responding
more intensely to stress, what you get is a small local version, maybe a few inches in
diameter of the organismic bystander effect.
The bystander effect refers to things that are well distributed through the body but
the intense signals such as a cell that is approaching or already turned into cancer
will chronically produce an excess of lactic acid even when it gets oxygen.
And so there will be a gradient of lactic acid surrounding that cell that irritates
and disturbs the nearby cells which then begin producing lactic acid and that spreads maybe
through a few centimeters of solid tissue, just the local diffusion causes a visible
gradient ending up in a gradient of DNA damage and mutations or it's hard to list all of
the factors other than lactic acid that are diffusing out of an injured cell.
They include carbon monoxide, nitrous oxide, inflammatory cytokines, a variety of those.
Everything that the body uses to respond protectively to damage.
It can help local tissues multiply faster so that they can fill in a wound for example,
accelerate some movement and replication of cells so that it's an essential part of healing
a wound but when it's coming, being originated from a mutated or seriously damaged group
of cells, then it's tending to simply spread the damage rather than accelerate the healing.
So all of these are normal healing factors like activating the local production of estrogen.
That's a normal part of repairing tissue damage but when it is prolonged and something
causes the body to be unable to turn it off, then each of these things adds to the spreading
effect as far as it diffuses locally, you'll see this gradient of deterioration including
mutations and meanwhile, it's adding a burden to the whole organism with more like the radiation
bystander effect.
Okay, you're listening to Ask Your Herb Doctor KMUD, 91.1 FM from 7.30pm till the
end of the show, 8 o'clock, you're invited to call in, the number is 707-923-3911, once
again 707-923-3911, Dr. Raymond Peat joining us.
So before I guess we get into the continued dialogue about mTOR and its importance as
a target for the treatment of cancer, I just wanted to outline this differentiation that
I started with the show with in terms of mechanistic versus holistic approach to treatment.
I read an article in preparing for this which was pretty exhaustive and had a lot of good
reference material in its own right as well as lots of natural and alternative inhibitors
as well as synthetic inhibitors of course because it was a chemical journal article.
But basically, they discussed the phosphoenositide 3-phosphate AKT mTOR pathway as a three-branched
signaling pathway and we're discussing that saying essentially approximately 70% of ovarian
and breast cancers are activated by a derangement in this pathway and then also saying that
about 90% of lung adenocarcinomas show an aberrant activation of this pathway and then
40% or so of squamous cell carcinomas are activated by this pathway and last month we
talked about mTOR for the first time and you had mentioned mTOR1 and mTOR2 as being subsets
of mTOR and we kind of came up with the etiology of mTOR and its discovery and its reference
to rapamycin and how that was discovered to be a good novel treatment to block this inflammatory
pathway of which cancer uses.
So would you just outline briefly again the mTOR1 and mTOR2.
The one form is an activating phosphorylating enzyme that when you're normally fed and growing
up it's what mediates between eating more and growing more and if you overeat at any
time you tend to overproduce this growth factor that necessarily leads to the degenerative
diseases excess calorie intake is very important and the activation of cells will turn on mTOR
and synthesis and growth such that intracellular calcium which calcium should mostly be outside
the cells but inside the cell it's an activating factor that increases mTOR.
The two form of the enzyme does similar things but it's fairly insensitive to the usual signals
such as overeating but depends mostly on growth hormone and many kinds of stress will turn
on an excess of growth hormone.
Women have spectacularly high levels of growth hormone compared to men as a result of estrogen
reducing effect so that growth hormone has some particular ways of affecting our handling
of fat that's basically the way the mTOR2 is turned on through high growth hormone.
And these growth hormones in their own right are proliferative agents that would promote
cancer growth okay so when I read about this mTOR, PI3K for want of a shorter term for it
and AKT pathways it looked like it wasn't just about mTOR that we had discussed last
month but that these other two arms of the same signaling messenger system the phosphorinoxetide
and the AKT pathway were also very good targets for shutting down essentially the it almost
seemed like it was shutting down the energy pathway which I found a little hard to reconcile
with given that thyroid hormone and progesterone being anti-inflammatory and energy conservative
mechanisms were concerned that the kind of energy production side of things was something
to be almost turned off in terms of having a beneficial effect on slowing cancers down
and perhaps this is the same mechanism by which the calorie control or calorie restriction
producing a greater longevity in people is you know is achieved.
Yeah the overeating and mTOR and so on tend to favor the oxidation of fats over glucose
and so when that happens you're basically slowing down the constructive part of energy
metabolism and shifting over towards some of these risky simple growth pathways.
So what do you think about shutting down not just mTOR but these other two pathways that
are linked as a kind of three branched target I mean it's not in the mechanistic terms which
is what the subject was about in terms of being holistic because it's not looking for
a side or killing effect it's looking and a lot of the things that were listed were
flavonoids and these were biologically active molecules found in fruits and vegetables of
which the kind of you know five servings of fruit and vegetables a day either is based
on in terms of good health and not just from a vitamin C perspective but the antioxidant
flavonoids whether or not because I was looking for mTOR inhibitors and it seemed as I'd mentioned
I think last month that there's things like resveratrol from the polygonum one of those
the really massive polygonums that kind of take over everything if you're not careful
if you plant them based in Japan I think also China is fairly endemic with it but they come
from you know grape skins is one of the main sources of resveratrol and then the berries
things like blueberries and bilberries and cranberries and I know oranges and other citrus
fruits contain these flavonoids and then I saw two other two other herbs and they caught
my attention one was a Chinese herb platycodon grandiflorus which contained this compound
called platycodin D and then another Chinese herb magnolia grandiflora containing a product
called honokiol and they were using those as both AKT blocking and mTOR inactivating substances
as long along with all the synthetic substances that they listed and two or three of which
were kind of often repeated but in terms of the energy quenching activity of flavonoids
in terms of free radical liberation so when people use flavonoids if they've got an inflammatory
disorder that's kind of systemic and widespread how these antioxidants for want of a better
work and quench the free radical generating effect of inflammation or that inflammation
has how this can be part and parcel of an anti-cancer approach holistic anti-cancer approach rather
than mechanistically poisoning the cancer cell which I think a lot of chemo well definitely
radiotherapy does but I think a lot of chemotherapy in the past especially has targeted cancer
cells in a killing way well what do you think about the the as I know you use co2 promotion
you know generating higher than regular physiological levels of co2 as being protective and then
obviously the other protective molecules like progesterone and aspirin and other compounds
that would increase your co2 what do you think about those things that I mentioned in the
flavonoids and or the other the other substances that have as energetic they do directly quench
the free radicals and are protected that way but I think are more basic effect is that they
intensify the cells normal cytochrome oxidase based oxidation by speeding up the energy
producing oxidation through the electron transport chain but that process prevents and reduces
or prevents the random oxidation that creates free radical damage and so it's a lot more
general and fundamental to intensify respiratory energy than to try to use the antioxidant
function if you think in terms of antioxidants it can go wrong because cancer is better than
anything at creating antioxidant effects part of their wildness is their ability to defend
themselves against free radical damage chemotherapy and radiation are intended to kill cancer
cells by way of free radical damage but they have an antioxidant system that uses high
production of electrons basically the excess of lactic acid causes an excess of electrons
that will end the cycle or quench the free radicals but meanwhile they're failing to
activate normal energy producing oxidation so you were talking earlier if you got dental
x-rays or other x-rays that it affected stuff near it if you were going to be exposed to
x-rays what sorts of foods or other things would you want to do to help protect yourself
things such as a thyroid magnesium and progesterone which promote the production of carbon dioxide
rather than lactic acid and then all of these other protective things of flavonoids and caffeine
aspirin and so on I think basically Dr. Peat is what you what it sounds like you and Andrew
are describing is cancer involves a lot of inflammation and a lot of these compounds
are acting as anti-inflammatories and increasing normal cellular respiration yeah that's really
a secret of thyroid function it's anti-inflammatory by directing oxygen towards consuming these
electrons that would otherwise cause inflammation because when the body's inflamed then it results
in a lactic acid respiration which is very damaging and inflammatory and increases the
loose electrons that are susceptible to random oxidation right okay you're listening to Ask
Your Herb Doctor KMUD Garberville 91.1 FM from now until the end of the show eight o'clock
you're invited to call in at number 707 923 3911. So in terms of the use of agents that
would block mTOR or block either the phosphorinositol 3-phosphate or the AKT pathway do you think
there's any because I also saw when I was looking at this that they come up with second
generation mTOR inhibitors I know they talked about the first I think you mentioned them
last month Sirolimus temsirolimus and everolimus as being analogs here but they also talked
about these second generation inhibitors they calling them ATP competitive mTOR kinase inhibitors
such as torin 1 and torin 2 do you do you think these molecules that compete with ATP
the energy currency of the cell do you think these have some mileage and value in terms
of the thing of what I have trouble with is conceptualizing interfering with energy production
that doesn't sound like it will end well yeah the central thing you need is to stabilize
the cells right because you always mentioning sugar being very important and not to not
to you know starve someone from sugar and not just for diabetes but that's when you
first mentioned it but for cancer and it's not at all scientifically rationalized that
that is a good way to go about yeah because the starving cancer emits signals that tells
the body to convert its own tissues muscles skin nerves to glucose to amino acids which
can be turned into glucose so when you start with cancer cell it tells the body to start
breaking itself down to provide the food at once and then they also went on to discuss
the cancers enduring cancer metabolism is strongly or at least the angiogenesis of cancer
the creation of novel vessels to bring blood and nutrients etcetera to the cancer which
is in kind of heightened state that the mentioned we've mentioned this before the hypoxia inducible
factor the activation of that was very responsible for driving and promoting cancer and how things
like vascular endothelial growth factor are other substances which drive cancer's production
so blocking you know blocking hypoxia inducible factor is something that I know you've talked
about in the past when we've done shows similar to this and that tends to go with activating
carbonic and hydrate which is the cells way of disposing of acidic carbon dioxide but
when that is too active it causes the cell to become alkaline leading to the production
of lactic acid that's very central to the cancer metabolism is to create alkalinity
inside the cell by activating the enzyme that converts carbon dioxide from from its acidic
form to the carbonate carbonic acid form okay so for those for those who are listening that
I wanted to run through some other natural mTOR inhibitors and I think I mentioned last
month turmeric turmeric is getting a lot of press for its anti-rheumatic anti-inflammatory
effects for its anti-cancer effects and probably gets its anti-cancer kudos from being a natural
mTOR inhibitor and then resveratrol mentioned that from polygonum cuspidatum and then a
compound whose abbreviation is EGCG epigallocatechin gallate from green tea as well as diethylmethane
and caffeine I was pleased to see caffeine there saying that this may inhibit mTOR signaling
directly and indirectly and then I saw two other substances here that caught my attention
and one was a substance called shogal from ginger root and there was an article reference
saying it inhibited the PI3K AKT mTOR pathway by directly targeting AKT1 and AKT2 but not
the PI3K or the mTOR pathway so ginger was used there specifically for colon cancer and
then I know you're not into the kind of pre-diabetes treating drugs but metformin do you have any
good things to say about metformin because metformin was actually listed as one of those
things to inhibit mTOR yeah the only drawback is that it acts to inhibit part of the electron
transport chain so it's incurring the mitochondria while also doing the beneficial thing of turning
off mTOR so it's good to be cautious about metformin because there's not enough known
about it but still its effects are generally protective through inhibiting mTOR okay and
then do you think there's much value in using some of these substances as a potential treatment
for Alzheimer's and I saw other references for neuro vegetative disorders and then I
think there may have been a Parkinson indication because of the amyloid beta that was quote
unquote treated or decreased and the neurofibrillary triangles that could be mitigated by using
some of these substances because of their effect on mTOR and mTOR's kind of downstream
effects on amyloid production yeah inflammation is involved in all of the degenerative processes
and so the anti-inflammatory anti-mTOR things are turning out to be protective against obesity
Alzheimer's rheumatoid arthritis lupus anything you can think of turns out to involve inflammation
at this route okay let me give out the number we do have a caller but if people would like
to call in it's 707-923-3911 Dr. Raymond Peat with us so caller you're on the air where
you from what's your question hello um Andrew and Sarah this is Margaret and Dr. Peat I'm
grateful for your show um I'm from Garberville and I you're mentioning turmeric uh caught
me because uh I use turmeric in uh daily pretty much but I noticed I know that there's a tendency
in our society to find something like turmeric or other extractives from other herbs and
things and it's like oh this is this is so great I'm gonna put it in capsule and take
you know like five millimeters of it every day or five centimeters or not centimeters
but but you know milligrams and and and um I was wondering if you would address uh whether
that's been really beneficial or if it's if it's beneficial enough to take it in your
ordinary diet you know just just as it as it comes kind of do we have to really sock
it to our bodies with all of these um uh extracts and pills and things you know I think is that
clear the question I think you can overeat on the so-called protective things uh same
with vitamin C uh instead of being uh antioxidant it becomes pro-oxidant when it begins producing
excess electrons in cells uh-huh and and what about the other the other lesser um like like
turmeric comes to mind because I do use that uh I know people that take it in little capsules
every day and it seems excessive to me but I'm not sure is it beneficial at that level
or or what I think I think some of this comes from uh studying uh populations in countries
that use it in their cuisine so whether the Indian subcontinent where they use or the
Asian subcontinent you know where they use a a lot of um turmeric and or ginger uh and
these and these other substances is concerned I think they have fairly low incidences of
colorectal cancer and I think they've kind of put the two and two together when they've
looked at uh turmeric um and it's anti-inflammatory activity as positing that as a potential mechanism
by which they've you know have fairly low incidences well the thing is they use it as
a matter of course in their daily lives we tend to say this is great I'm going to load
myself up with it and I'm I'm just thinking that maybe that's not as beneficial as we
think it might be maybe we should just follow that pattern and and use it in a more uh an
integrative part kind of way you know uh in part and more in a culinary fashion yes thanks
Sarah yeah yeah so that we're it's we're eating our medicine instead of taking cat
yeah yeah so remember too is a lot of um traditional cultures make peas out of these things they're
not just like you know swallowing tablespoons of turmeric root they're putting some of their
cooking and if they're going to make it into a medicine they make it into a tea which helps
to attract the medicinal constituents like a tincture does without having to have all
the extra fiber and potential extra heavy metals that are in herbs that don't get extracted
in the tea in the tincture yeah that's like they would in the root of turmeric that's a
very good point because having looked at these botanicals and put them through icpms to see
what levels of kind of the california for um you know heavy metals arsenic, cadmium,
lead and mercury are within these herbs as part of a gmp process to produce um these
extracts and sell them i know from from data raw data that the um the plant itself the
root uh contains very high levels and some cases of those compounds and the extracts
contain virtually none and so the the extract process um i would say this much is very clean
compared to the root of the actual herb if you were going to consume this and so we've
done shows on this with fish in the ocean and showing how much arsenic, cadmium, lead
and mercury is in them the same goes for any plant material that you would use that was
basically to ingest it in the powder or capsule form which is why we're not at all um in agreement
with capsules and powders over extracts because extracts do not bring out the heavy metal
content of the raw material it's as simple as that and i can show you and also extract
tinctures they concentrate the material you know you concentrate the medicinal constituents
well thank you very much i appreciate your uh your help thank you you're welcome good
night Margaret for your call okay i think we have another call on the line so let's
take this next caller call away from what's your question hi my name is Margie and i would
like a clarification on when Dr. Peat says um sugar does that mean just um fructose or
uh honey natural sugars yeah um and i can take my answer off the earth incidentally
where are you from i'm from pepperwood pepperwood okay so yeah you know you kind of read my
mind i was gonna say that and i wasn't going to be devil devil's advocate but it sounded
like it was going to be a moment ago in going to answer the previous callers questions i
was gonna say what about sugar we just want to get that from carbohydrates or do we want
to get it from sugar or honey because i think Dr. Peat would say to get it from honey and
to get it from sugar um but yeah Dr. Peat it's also good uh coming from starch or other more
complex healthy starches carbohydrates but uh the problem is some of those like sweet
potatoes are such mixtures they have uh woody material and fats indigestible things mixed
in with the otherwise uh useful carbohydrates uh so you can't just say that uh annual starch
is going to be equivalent to glucose or sucrose or honey it depends on whether it's digestible
well i think i want to can i go back to the sugar issue and the cancer issue that you
touched on earlier every cell in the body needs glucose to operate so if you don't eat
any kind of sugar your body's going to turn on a harmful metabolism to make sugar and
and that is involving lactic acid correct Dr. Peat and high cortisol isn't necessary
to mobilize and break down the protein to make amino acids and and the glucose which
also promotes cancer cortisol also promotes cancer it's a stress promoter so it weakens
your immunity against it yeah lowers your immune system like everybody knows steroids
suppress the immune system and cortisol is a natural steroid your body will make when
you starve your body of sugar glucose so i know doctor you've said that honey and white
sugar cane sugar are identical in their structure they both are sucrose which is half fructose
and half glucose yeah and the pure fructose on the market for many people it has allergenic
effects because of its manufactured in a more complex way than with sucrose you simply concentrate
the juice remove the impurities from the cane juice to make white sucrose but to make fructose
chemical and enzyme processes are used introduce some trace allergens so you're cautious about
using what they call a powdered fructose right so you would recommend honey or cane sugar
over a fructose because of the process that the fructose goes there even though fructose
is more nutritious sugar yeah and and the other thing too is i know doctor you don't recommend
people just eat white sugar by the table to without balancing it with a healthy fat healthy
saturated fat like coconut oil and or butter and a protein or at least with just a protein
so that it's not just an instant sugar spike yeah it can be used in the pure form for example
is a mild analgesic for babies they give them a bit of pure sucrose and is for pain killer
and in areas that lack penicillin a big wound that otherwise would be fatal has been packed
with pure store-bought white sugar and it has a thermosidal effect as well as a protective
effect so also honey does too they pack wounds with honey as well yeah so it has its specific
therapeutic effects besides its protective nutritional effects right i hope that answered
that caller's question there okay good i think there was a caller that came in but it is
four minutes too i don't think we can do it it's almost three minutes to the hour one
thing i wanted to mention before we're finished is that vitamin D is a very important inhibitor
of mTOR because it works on many other levels inhibits things that would promote mTOR reduces
the processes that would amplify a little inflammation into a big inflammation such as a blocking
prostaglandin formation okay excellent so dr p do appreciate you joining us again on the
show and i'll give out your information and thank you so much okay thank you thank you
dr p okay so for those who've listened to this march 18 2022 edition of ask your herb doctor
something just happened try saying what you just said again Andrew I hung up and everything
cut out on the board can you hear me uh okay here uh huh try the other mic
oh no well i hate to have a rough ending to that but uh something weird just happened
on the k-mud ancient board here and uh i'm gonna have to fill out a technical malfunction
thing and i'll please support redwood community radio because we really really really do need
a new board thank you so much for joining us it's time to step out on a wing and a prayer
for you.
hello and welcome to the top of the day oh here we are we both are you made it all right
have you found the microphone yeah i see it all right all right we're in the vicinity
hey there ma yeah what a coincidence here's a little card i found mind read that this
program is supported by the redwood palace a full-service restaurant that offers a relaxed
dining experience on the avenue of the giant offering a full selection of local beer and
wine humbled bay oysters cheese charcuterie boards and special dinners the redwood palace
is located in maranda and can be reached at 707-223-5749 menu and more online at redwoodpalacemaranda.com
to go and dining in from wednesday through saturday 5 to 9 pm oh by the way